the worst economic crisis of any major
economy in the last 12 months
unemployment at five percent and as the
chancellor said forecast to rise
to six point five percent the debtor
over
two trillion i'm sure this budget will
look better on instagram
in fact this week's pr video
cost the taxman so much i was half
expecting to see a line
in the obr forecast for it
but even the chancellor's film crew will
struggle to put a positive spin on this
after the decisions of the last year and
the decade of neglect
we needed a budget to fix the
foundations of our economy
to reward our key workers to protect the
nhs
and to build a more secure and
prosperous economy for the future
instead what we got was a budget that
papered over the cracks
rather than rebuilding the foundations a
budget that shows the government doesn't
understand
what went wrong in the last decade or
what's needed
in the next the chancellor may
think the chancellor may think that this
is time for a victory lap
but i'm afraid this budget won't feel so
good
for the millions of key workers who are
having their pay frozen
for the businesses swamped by debt
and the families paying more in council
tax
and the millions of people who are out
of work
or worried about losing their job and
although the chancellor spoke for
almost an hour we heard nothing
about a long-term plan to fix social
care
the chancellor may have forgotten about
it but the labour party
never will the british
people will rightly ask why has britain
why has britain suffered a worse
economic crisis than any major economy
the answer is staring us in the face
first the chancellor's decisions in the
last year this is the chancellor
who bought who blocked a circuit break
in september
ignoring the science he told the british
people
to live with coronavirus and live
without fear
a few weeks later we were forced into an
even longer and more painful lockdown
whatever spin the chancellor tries to
put on the figures today
as a result of his decisions we've
suffered
deeper economic damage and much worse
outcomes
a madam deputy speaker that is nothing
compared with the decade
of political choices that meant that
britain went into this crisis
with nico with an economy built on
insecurity and inequality
the chance referred to the last 10 years
we've got an economy as a result of
those 10 years with 3.6 million people
in insecure work
we're still where wages stagnated for a
decade
over four million children living in
poverty
and critically we went into this crisis
with a hundred thousand unfilled posts
in the nhs
and where social care was ignored and
underfunded for a decade
members opposite voted for all of that
today's budget doesn't even recognize
that let alone
rectify it it's clear that chancellor is
now betting on a recovery fueled by a
consumer spending blitz
in fairness in fairness if my next door
neighbor
was spending tens of thousands of pounds
redecorating their flat i'd probably do
the same
but the central problem in our economy
is a deep-rooted
insecurity and inequality and this
budget
isn't the answer to that the chancellor
barely mentioned inequality
let alone try to address it so rather
than the big
transformative budget we needed this
budget simply papers
over the cracks if this had been a
budget for the long term
it would have had a plan a plan to
protect our nhs
a plan to fix social care and i can tell
you this a labor budget
would have had the nhs and care homes
front and center
but this budget is almost silent on
those questions
if this had been a budget to rebuild the
foundations
it would have fixed our broken social
security system
instead the chancellor has been dragged
kicking and streaming
to extend the 20 pound uplift in
universal
credit but only for a few months once
again
deferring the problem as a result
insecurity
and the threat of use of losing a
thousand pounds a year still hang over
six million
families they asked what we had to
what we would do we would keep the
uplift until a new fairer system could
be put in place
if this budget if this budget was
serious
about rebuilding our shattered economy
it would have included a credible plan
to tackle unemployment
the chancellor said very little about
the kickstart scheme
no doubt because no doubt because
the prime minister says rubbish that's
no doubt because the kickstart scheme is
only helping 1 in 100 eligible young
people
rubbish is the right word prime minister
in six months in six months it's
supported just
22 000 young people yet youth
unemployment is set to reach 1 million
like so much of this budget the
chancellor's offer is
nowhere near the scale of the task
and of course the biggest challenge this
country is the climate emergency
the chancellor just talked up his green
credentials
but his budget stops way short of what
was needed or what's happening in other
countries
this budget should have included a major
green stimulus
bringing forward billions of pounds of
investment to create new jobs
a new green infrastructure instead
instead the government is trying to
build a new coal mine
which we now learn might not even work
for british steel
if anything sums up this government's
commitment
to a green recovery and jobs of the
future it's building a coal mine
we can't even use
if the government was serious about
tackling insecurity
and that those most at risk from covid
this budget would have fixed the broken
system of statutory sick pay
and at the very least filled the glaring
holes in isolation payments
this isn't difficult to fix the
government should just make the 500
pound
isolation payment available to everyone
who needs it
that would be money well spent and a
year into the pandemic
it's a disgrace that it's not
if the government was serious about
fixing the broken housing market
it would have announced plans for a new
generation of genuinely affordable
council houses
instead 230 council homes
230 000 council homes have been lost
since 2010
yet the chancellor focused today on
returning
to subsidising 95 of mortgages
now i know what you're thinking i've
heard that somewhere before
i've heard that somewhere before maybe
it was because the prime minister
announced it five months ago in his
conference speech
no i don't think anybody heard that
i remember now i remember now it's what
osborne and cameron came up with in
2013.
and what did that do what did that do
it fueled a housing bubble it pushed up
prices
and made owning a home more difficult so
much for generation by i've been saying
for weeks that this budget will go
back i didn't expect the chancellor to
lift a failed policy from eight years
ago
this budget fell far short of the
transformative change we needed to turbo
charge our recovery
for the decades to come there was no
credible plan to ease the burden of debt
hanging over
so many businesses this is estimated at
70 billion pounds
this budget asks businesses to start
paying that money back
whether they're profitable or not
that affects millions of businesses
it will hold back growth
because businesses will have to pay back
money they never wanted to borrow
instead of being able to invest in their
futures and create jobs in their local
areas
it's both unfair and economically
illiterate
this budget also fell far short of what
was needed
to support the self-employed and
freelancers
unless of course you're one of the
chancellor's photographers
after a year of inaction after a year of
inaction
we'll look at the details of what the
chancellor announced
but it certainly looks like from the
figure of six hundred thousand that he
mentioned
that millions will still be left out in
the cold
the chancellor's one normally long-term
policy was his
references to leveling up
but what does that actually look like
it's not the transformative shift in
power wealth and resources we need
to rebalance our economy it's not the
bold long-term plan we need to up-skill
our economy
to tackle educational attainment or to
raise life
expectancy it certainly isn't a plan to
focus government resources
on preventative services and early years
for the chancellor leveling up seems to
mean
moving some parts of the treasury to
darlington
creating a few free ports and renouncing
funding
that isn't leveling up it's giving up
and instead instead of putting blind
faith in freeports
the chancellor would be better served
making sure the
government's brexit deal actually works
for britain's manufacturers who now face
more red tape
when they were promised less for our
financial services
still waiting for the chancellor to make
good on his promises
for the small businesses and fishing
communities whose goods and produce
are now left unsold in warehouses and
for our artists and performers
who just want to be able to tour
turning to other parts of the statement
we'll wait for the detail about the
so-called super deduction
but it's unlikely to make up for the 10
years
when the levels of private investment
growth have trailed
so many other countries of course we
welcome the creation of the national
infrastructure
bank something we've called for for
years
although it'd been better if the
government hadn't sold off the green
investment bank
in the first place
we also welcome the introduction of
green saving bonds
i have to say what a good idea it is to
introduce a new set of recovery bombs
the trouble is that the scale of what
the chancellor announced today is
nowhere near ambitious
enough and the long overdue commitments
to extend furlough
business rate relief and the v80 cut on
hospitality
are welcome but there is no excuse
for holding the announcement of this
support back until today
and of course we'll look at the detail
but madam deputy speaker there are very
few silver linings in this budget
the imf and the oecd have said now isn't
the time for tax rises
we're in the middle of a once in 300
year crisis
our economy is still shut our businesses
are on life support
so it's right that corporation tax isn't
rising this year or next
of course in the long run corporation
tax should go up
the decade-long corporation tax
experiment
by this government has failed
but no taxes should have been raised in
the teeth of this economic crisis
so it's ex so it's extraordinary that
the
chancellor is plowing ahead with a two
billion pound
council tax rise affecting households
across
the country so why is he doing that
why is he doing that when every
economist would tell him not to do it
perhaps we find the answer in this
week's sunday times
rich's argument let's do all this now
far away from the election as possible
or the telegraph on the 27th of january
raising taxes now means that they can be
reduced ahead of the next election
soon act tells mps or the mail
in september soon act to hike taxes
and lower than before the election let
me be crystal clear
the proper basis for making tax
decisions is the economic cycle
not the electoral cycle
madam deputy speaker behind the spin the
videos and the photo ops
we all know the chancellor doesn't
believe in an active and enterprising
government
we know we know he's itching to get back
to his free market principles
and to pull away support as quickly as
he can one day these restrictions will
end
one day we'll all be able to take our
masks off and so will the chancellor
and then you'll see who he really is and
this budget
sets it up perfectly because this is a
budget
that didn't even attempt to rebuild the
foundations of our economy
or to secure the country's long-term
prosperity
instead it did the job the chancellor
always intended
a quick fix papering over the cracks
the party opposite spent a decade
weakening the foundations of our economy
now they pretend they can rebuild it but
the truth is
they won't confront what went wrong in
the past and they have no plan
for the future thank you madam deputy
speaker